what's going on reject nation
i'm here today with my buddy andrew
gordon andrew it's been a long time
since i've been on the channel
yeah i mean uh there wasn't anything
preventing me from coming on not like a
pandemic or anything so
nope nope not in the way at all but
andrew is someone who gets tested
regularly
for his work and he's clean right now so
i said come on by
because undoubtedly when it came to the
first spider-man game before i ever even
played it
he was the number one person championing
for me to play that game
you played that one like at least four
times but you just beat this game
last night right it's a pretty short
game yeah it was uh definitely pretty
short and you and i were kind of talking
about it earlier this is
kind of like something in between a dlc
and a sequel disguised as that but i
mean something that we can play in
between the next spider-man game
whenever that comes out but yeah i know
i mean it was definitely a little bit
quick it's enjoyable especially the
glitches
yeah there were some glitches in here
man yeah it wasn't it wasn't like
overly abundant but some of them were
just a little obvious but yeah and yeah
to clarify we did get it on the ps4
i got on a ps4 pro do you have a pro no
i'm not a pro
so i'm so much better than you and
everybody you are so much except we
didn't get it on ps5 so none of us win
but if any of you want to donate one to
us
yeah it comes with a free upgrade though
i really like the game overall you know
like in i guess the basic way to summon
up i mean yeah because we're going to
talk about some spoilers here we won't
talk for
too long the spoilers that just stood
out to us with some obviously basic
things to cover as well i would give it
somewhere between like an 8.5 to 9 out
of 10
somewhere there because in a lot of ways
this game was
exactly what i expected it to be and in
some ways that's like a fantastic
perfect thing right because i expected a
great game
and it's extremely extremely fun yet at
the same time there's something there
that's i don't quite know what it is
that was missing for me yet and i'm
hoping to discover that in the middle of
us having this conversation
overall i did really have a blast doing
it like the gameplay was exceptional i
thought the swinging around was even
more fun
than the previous spider-man game you
notice how like miles he moves in an
amateurish
i mean it's also kind of to like how you
would expect a teenager
to uh if had given these kind of powers
to swing so i liked how they
definitely varied with how different he
swings then from how peter swings
yeah yeah obviously two you know miles
is definitely le i mean he definitely
jokes around quarks around a little bit
but nowhere on the level of like peter
parker he's more down to business when
yeah when he you know he's got a mission
to do
you know i agreed with you it was
definitely what i expect i would say i
mean i didn't have too many flaws in
this game for the most part other than
like we just mentioned a little bit of
the glitches here but that's you know
more uh
nitpicking at that point i'd say some of
the only things for me is you know it
was a little bit predictable
with a few things uh that i personally
guess were gonna happen sometimes you
know that's not always a terrible thing
but
you know in this case like i said it
wasn't you know i could see a couple
things coming a mile away but
overall a mile away no pun intended but
uh yeah
the the swinging was i thought it was
definitely improved upon from the the
previous spider-man game it definitely
packed a few emotional punches as well
uh as the previous one i wouldn't go on
the same level as that one but it
definitely was emotionally engaging you
know like the previous one for sure
well the previous one didn't bring me to
tears i thought the previous one
was more intense they're really building
it up
until you know the the breakout at raft
that was like oh my god
and here i found that towards the end of
the game it did actually bring me to
tears
um at the specific part well i'm just
going to talk about this game as if you
guys have played it the specific part
with the tinkerer after she sacrifices
herself
miles wakes up and the people around him
kind of like spider-man 2. yeah yeah
yeah
they're protecting his identity and
protecting him yeah yeah and how
his first thought even though he has
helped save the day his first thought is
him making sure everyone's okay and
there was something about that heroic
journey for this guy and how when he
first wakes up from being unconscious
and almost dying
his first thought is ever is everyone
else okay his journey
into really embracing his own version of
spider-man did bring me to tears in that
specific moment when the
when the people around him when haley
brings the mask over and everyone's
protecting his identity it didn't move
me emotionally there
what i realized by the time it got to
that point because i was what i was
noticing throughout the game was like
okay there's some parts of this to feel
a little bit repetitive because it's
more it's a smaller story it's more
contained you're mainly fighting the
underground
or you're fighting the the rocks on
people then you get like a couple of
fights a rhino
you get a fight with the tinkerer and
you get a fight with the prowler but the
fight with the prowler is not really
that difficult
those fights were definitely pretty
simple i mean obviously when comparing
to the other games you gotta fight like
six guys at once at some
points the other game was definitely a
little more intense but uh you know
harping a little bit back on
the last game not bringing you to tears
for me when aunt may
you know when peter had to make that
choice that kind of brought me up oh
yeah i kind of forgot about that right
um but yeah no i i agree with you in
regards to this game where i was
definitely brought to tears in regards
to
you know finn's sacrifice and she also
saw what you know miles was about to
sacrifice herself so she understood like
you know that hatred was getting in the
way you know the overall bigger picture
and she saw like what she was about to
do not only destroying harlem but i mean
her best friend was about
to be you know killed and she didn't
really want to fight miles the entire
time she just wanted him out of the way
so she could get her revenge on what
you know simon krieger had done to her
brother so from that perspective like
i empathize with her i understood i
didn't agree with what she was doing but
i could understand why she was doing it
and that's good character
building to me and you know that's
that's the depth that these characters
had and i really enjoyed that portion of
the game for sure
yeah but the point i was getting at was
that even though the like what you're
talking about with finn
even though the game is technically not
bigger in
scope it's a much more contained one it
works because the characters that you're
focusing on
feel a lot more personal everything
about this feels more personal to miles
you know you have finn
who is like a childhood friend of his
you know like a brother-sister dynamic
but also maybe love interest dynamic too
and then you got his uncle aaron who is
it's his uncle who's the prowler i
actually enjoyed the side missions a
little bit more in this game
as well i thought this was more focused
on keeping everything a lot more
intertwined
because with its themes of you know
proving himself in the way of how he can
live up to the spider-man mantle a
but he's also honoring the legacy of his
dad
and trying to be a hero in both
departments find his own identity learn
a deal with sacrifices
what i loved about his mirroring journey
with uh
finn aaron lost his dad in the last one
so he could have been a bad guy
too or finn lost someone that she loved
and she ended up down this bad path i
love how they're like two opposite sides
of the same coin
thematically this actually worked a
little bit
stronger because for the fact that it is
more of a contained story works for me
because the story feels a lot more
personal
in terms of its immediacy with his
connection to characters
other than simon krieger i just learned
before filming that you said joel
this voice by joel from the last of us
what did you think of him i mean he's
your typical bad guy i mean you know
he's greedy wants to uh you know uh
show why his product is the best thing
in the world you know doesn't care who
gets killed in the process he just wants
to get rich doesn't feel like human life
is very valuable
your typical bag i mean there was no i
mean they didn't go too much into the
character i mean they showed us a you
know a few scenes here and there but i
i don't know i didn't think there was
too much depth in this villain in
comparison
obviously you know the scope is
different so it's not fair to keep
comparing to the original game you know
in regards to
you know what we got in the previous
game with the our villains you know i
just thought there was a lot more
character depth uh with those villains
uh
in comparison to this obviously this guy
doesn't have a superpower or anything
other than
he's rich his batman he's not even that
smart he has other people do all the
crazy scientific stuff for him
yeah that is what a smart guy is what
i'll say though is there are times where
i thought the writing on the chara
on certain characters kind of lacked but
the performances of everyone were still
really good same thing can be said for
troy baker because i agree on everything
about the simon krieger character
he's set up to be the main villain at
least the way
it alludes to that in the beginning of
the game but he's not really the
antagonist of the story
is finn simon krieger very
two-dimensional
in terms of how he's written but i
thought i thought troy baker was having
a blast
playing him though you know he's troy
baker's phenomenal for sure
and there were times with finn where she
kind of got on my nerves
and not in the good kind of villain way
the way how it is would
finn is kind of similar to the way it is
with doc
ock and peter but doc ock you know he
has the thing going on
in it yeah it's like he's got the
emotional problems but he's also got
what is that called the
the inhibitor chip he's got the
inhibitor chip which is messing with his
mindset
his emotions and with her she's
constantly
i think the only thing got up my nerves
is like stop lying to me you keep lying
to him like you're a liar too what are
you talking about yeah
that that was the only thing that kind
of got on my nerves totally
understandable i think she just felt so
betrayed she let miles into the
underground
you know and then he obviously lied
about that she felt betrayed when
you know uncle aaron kind of sold them
out you know so
she had i mean again she was already
dealing with vengeance and and revenge
so when you add
your best friend you know lied to you in
the other two capacities it just does
not make for a very good recipe i will
also say too peter parker picked a hell
of a few weeks to go out of town yeah i
know right yeah
perfect timing but what do you think of
his new look
yeah did not grow on me yeah i was
hoping that it would go i mean
the only time it didn't distract me is
when you go to the flashback at the
museum yeah with him in daca
yeah for some reason that was i noticed
later on
i was like oh that was the only time i
wasn't pulled out by his look
well it's just we just got so
emotionally engaged with that look from
the previous game i mean just like his
facial reactions you know
how he just emotionally pulled you in
with that uh the the face that they had
in the previous game it's just
oh i screw up a good thing was perfect
it really hit me
why why bother me so much is because in
the other spider-man game he's in his
mid-20s right he feels like a
character's had a lot of experience
under his belt yes
and then here he looks like a kid he's
younger than me
he's like the same age
and i've heard things of when it came
time to updating the games
graphics or the ps5 modeling or whatever
i don't know the technical terminology
that they justified changing his look
for but either way i don't think it
looks good
yeah but yuri lowenthal was terrific
again
i mean obviously limited amount of time
he has in this game
obviously in comparison in the last game
it's miles game and he as we mentioned
he's on vacation on assignment in europe
with mj he's her
uh freelance photographer but the the
time we do get to spend with peter other
than
checking out his f i mean when he's in
the mask because we want to enjoy more
now
yuri did a great job again i mean he's
he is spider-man
his voice at least he does a fantastic
job and you know the limited time we did
get to have i i
didn't really appreciate and enjoy his
chemistry with miles you know he does
feel like even though he doesn't
look like one from young he looks he
does feel like a mentor you know and
someone who does
a really good job he definitely does a
better job than obi-wan kenobi um
mentoring this guy than
obi-wan did with anakin yeah i thought
the i thought the mentoring
it's a good comparison i think the
mentoring was one of my favorite
elements of it like the act
one of this game i really enjoyed
working alongside peter parker i even
like
the setups of the training that that
peter's laid out for
the holograms the hologram yeah that was
really cool that was a blast to do
and it was another thing like there were
times where i felt like this the side
missions
you know how at times in this game and
like with the last one when
they're like all right well i guess i
have to just swing around the city and
do some missions you know when
they do the main story comes along again
yeah and i thought that the use of
that was better implemented here and
also the use
of like the doing the hologram mission
like i really wanted to keep doing it
like obviously we were kind of rushing
during our evenings to play the game
so we can talk about the game so we can
go back and do all those other side
missions but i am
itching to do those because i do find
those to be a big blast
i really also like the character with uh
the who does the asl um i love
that dynamic too and it made me want to
see a sequel where they're dating each
other
i love that ending where everyone's
protecting his identity and i thought
the way they brought harlem to life here
i've only been to harlem
once in my life did you see luke cage i
did not see luke cage nor miles morales
when i was there
what i thought was really cool about
this was this like yeah spider-man is
all about new york city and here you
could explore
you know new york city as well beyond
harlem but they really made
the community of harlem the life and
personality of that
feel very much lived in yeah and i loved
how this comes down to
he's our spider-man like he's harlem
spider-man feeling that community and
that's
that's what i mean they made that even
feel more personal spider-man protecting
new york yes that that's
that's his home town but it's new york
city and then here it's a very specific
city
where miles morales identity is tied
into and
i love that they really uh capitalized
off of that
i also was surprised by prowler that
suit was so cool it was a sick suit
i loved how prowler picked up on his
identity right away oh yeah
that was that was a good one i like that
i i really like when you see his name on
the subway card
yeah that was a good one i really was
like whoa okay he was not
a full-on villain in this game at all
yeah he was protecting his his nephew i
mean he does some he definitely is a
thief and does some things that are not
great but i mean at the end of the day
he's doing what he's doing to protect
his nephew yeah and i thought his
performance is really good too
i was expecting him to take this this
turn where he's full-on evil because
he's
prowler i love how he had this kind of
conflicting
protecting fatherly image he felt he had
to hold to miles because
you know aaron's brother miles's father
is gone i thought the complexity of that
relationship
was very much was written very well i
thought it was one of the strongest
written parts of this story oh i
completely agree and also too if you get
time to play
do those sound missions that uh he gives
you you you get more of the backstory um
what happened
between miles as father jefferson yeah
and also with uh aaron you get to see
like how they used to
bond and you know how they grew up with
each other like a lot of the different
places that they bonded over
and also you get to see kind of what
kind of broke them apart obviously and
being the prowler
you know it wasn't helping so jefferson
didn't want him uh
you know being around the family but no
i it was definitely very engaging i i
love that portion of the storyline
i always like when there's a family link
in there and you have that emotional
issue
and that you know and your hero
responsibility like what do i do do i
fight my family like and it was good on
both parts you know you got to see
you know both characters sides of it you
know again uncle aaron is or the
prowlers doing what he thinks is best to
because he wants to be in his family's
life that wasn't his choice
in regards to uh what happened uh with
his brother and him separating i mean
technically was in terms of you know the
life he chose but
he still wanted to be a part of their
lives and i like that part of it because
when he did sell them out he said don't
harm the boy
or catch the boy you know he want he did
want miles you know unharmed and the
only reason he wanted finn stopped is
because he worked for roxanne
and he didn't want her i mean possibly
destroying the city or
uh you know sending miles down the wrong
wrong way so i didn't always agree with
what he was doing but i understood
everything where he was coming from and
i appreciated that
you didn't also mention that line uh
towards the end of the game like this is
our spider-man harlem spider-man
i love that line that was that's one of
the best lines in the game and i'm
really glad they included that in there
i was brought to tears not because of
sadness in this game i was brought to
tears because i was touched by its
heroism what did you think about though
i gotta ask about back to the gameplay
when it came to the venom powers i loved
them
i loved using them but i thought it made
the game easier
way like so much easier i thought that
this game wasn't really
challenging and i feel like that's part
of my the thing that prevents it from
making it a 10 out of 10 for me because
don't get me wrong it's also
extremely fun but i rarely found it
difficult and i didn't play on i played
on the one right below hard whatever
that mode is called it wasn't normal
it's just it's whatever version of
normal is with the fancy text in the
neighborhood not friendly neighborhood
yeah but still i found like the first
game a little bit more challenging
because of that but the venomous stuff
is still really cool to use yeah i mean
and obviously
camouflage yeah i mean those are both
staples of things he can do in the comic
books of course
maybe what they could have done to uh
make you enjoy a little bit better is
i mean you get the venom power so often
so maybe when like you know you don't
get to earn it back as quickly it takes
a lot more time to get it back and like
you said it's a really cool thing to do
yeah it would have been cooler if they
didn't uh
you know give it to us as often as they
did because it felt less challenging
whereas the first game you don't even
get a venom power obviously because
peter doesn't have that ability like
miles does
visually and gameplay wise it was it was
awesome it was a blast
it's awesome no pun intended i would
have wanted to not be here yeah
right you just felt that it made the the
game play a little less challenging
which is what you
when you're spider-man you want to be
challenged you want to earn it it's kind
of like the die-hard effect with
bruce willis character in the first film
when he goes through all the [ __ ] he
goes through
to and by the end of the movie you're
like damn that was it yeah exactly
i think what might have been missing for
me is
there's not really that many bosses yeah
you know what i mean
rhino and prowler and fin and the tinker
yeah yeah like the prowler one doesn't
feel that threatening and honestly i
thought the prowler one was surprisingly
easy to do but i thought that might be
the most challenging one
right and uh tinkerers it was the
hardest one
it should be the hardest one because
that's the final boss tinker should be
the hardest one
maybe if they had like i don't really
know miles morales
rogue gallery like everyone knows batman
and spider-man's row gallery pretty well
but i don't really know miles's rogue
gallery and perhaps if they had a little
bit more of
them in there and then you made those
the really challenging ones you felt
like you really needed your venom or
something
then um i feel like that wouldn't really
have that complaint because
for most of the game it's it is you're
fighting the
underground and the rocks on yeah and
that feels kind of repetitive because
they're just
doing the same villains throughout the
whole game but the thing is i got to
clarify it
it's constantly extremely fun yes and i
think that's where
everything that i have an issue with
that's like it's always supplemented by
it's a blast when you're playing it
though it's always a blast it's like
you're hiding that fun so you don't uh
so you don't feel the repetitiveness as
much
we got it really quickly to talk about
the guy in the chair
thank you yeah he was and obviously yeah
i did too and ned's character from uh
spiderman homecoming spider-man far from
home
he's variations of that character no i
love the the
the interaction and the chemistry
between uh genki and miles is terrific i
mean
sometimes i just love swinging and just
listening them bicker back and
not bicker but just you know go back and
forth on what they're saying where he's
help helping him out with a mission or
saying hey i got to go on a podcast what
do i wear like
just yeah real life issues i love his
character and how he was helping uh
miles out he was great i thought their
chemistry was awesome and i thought the
jay jonah jameson podcast was just as
good
i didn't really i liked the other
podcast i didn't like it as
didn't find it anywhere near as engaging
i would have been fine with just jay
jonah james
podcast he is so entertaining hard one
to compare
it's hard to top jay jonah james yeah
and also rio morales i thought was a
really rich character i was kind of
surprised by just
how many people learned miles identity
in this game like
everyone knows who miles is it was
surprising but i also love how
supportive she still was she didn't have
any of that the cliche route of you
can't be doing this she
supported him um throughout this whole
journey and when it came time to
go after the big electronic rocks on
building to fight the tinker at the end
she yeah with the neuroform explosion
and all that yeah you know the words
jesus like yeah go for it you know
and i i love that and also aaron davis
turns himself into the police by the end
of this day
right and also he cuts a deal with them
to sell out simon krieger so he
in the end he did the right thing but
yeah i agree with you about rio
it was nice that we didn't get the
typical you know yeah i mean
it would be understandable she's her
it's his mother and she
shiori has lost uh her husband so it'd
be understandable for her not to wind
up the aunt may who knows yeah exactly
exactly it just came out a lot sooner
and you know without her dying in
in this case but yes i did like that
that they veered away from the typical
i don't want you to do this but yeah i
loved again their interactions too
they really feel like you know i love
their relationship they're very close
i also love to when they interact in
spanish with each other
that that was really cool at the
beginning where she's like get the
groceries i forgot the coconut milk i
gotta go here
he's like how does and he's like kind of
thinking like how does peter always come
up with all these excuses and all that
stuff the biggest thing i loved in this
game as well was miles's growth
throughout the game exactly
really crew into a hero i mean not that
he wasn't at the beginning just seeing
the responsibilities and everything he's
got to go through the emotional
you know punches no pun intended he's
got to fight with like characters that
he cares about in regards to uncle aaron
and
with finn and you know i just really
loved watching the character grow and
you even though it was a short quick
game you really did feel it
well i mean he starts off as very
insecure
and constantly comparing himself to
peter parker and i love how you start
off with him and peter and it ends with
him and peter yet your
your association and image to miles
morales
by the end of the game you're like no
he's fully formed now oh yeah you know
like
it's more than just he's got a suit it's
more than just this guy and a cooler
and i thought the suits were i i found
myself
switching around to suits depending on
where we were at in the story you know
they were more than just
cool suits i've i actually liked the uh
how some of the suits had some real
meaning to like the holiday one yeah you
know it was a cool one
i did i did get the into the
spider-verse one but
i think only on the ps5 is when it does
like the cool animations you do the
prowler
um okay well i'll leave it at that why
there's a way to
well the the if you do the sound
missions i was talking about where you
you know and couthy the backstory of uh
uncle aaron and uh jefferson
he gives you a suit it was like a
prowler suit oh snap yeah it was really
cool i guess what was missing for me was
just a little bit more i would like just
a little more bosses that's about it
yeah i agree and then we also got to
talk really quickly about the the
mid-credits scene we get that it's
obviously
setting up for the next spider-man game
we get to see uh harry in that in that
uh
his little bacca tank star wars
reference there with uh dr connors
yeah there's dr kirk carnes you see his
arm is missing and also we see norman
uh calls him uh kurt so we know that's
for sure the lizard yeah uh but yeah we
get to see that you know he's
kind of he wants him out of that tube
immediately and so this sets up him
being venom in the next game
yeah yeah venom it looks like he's got
the symbol they're gonna turn
they're gonna turn harry osborne into
we'll see
we'll see i'm sure the people in the
comments will let us know but i mean
it looks like he's got symbiote all over
him oh snap i didn't notice that no that
was really cool how they set that up and
then of course the end credits there's
two things that we noticed in the end
credits
it's not really a scene but a very nice
tribute to chadwick boseman who of
course we lost earlier in uh this year
and that was really nice they put like a
noble king and all that
yes rest in peace yes and uh also we got
to see
miles he had a an award for that him and
finn won
and he put it on i believe it was the
trinity church and uh you know
in memorial uh in tribute to her so i
thought that was a really nice touch
it's something that he's never going to
recover from emotionally at least but
he's still gonna fight on he's still
gonna keep doing his hero duties well
yeah i mean i played for a little bit
longer after that and then
he calls up his mom and his is saying
like i'm so conflicted on this you know
like it was her fault why all this
happened but i miss her and
you know and i love ending on kind of
that moral complexity note by the time
finn sacrificed herself i was like oh
man that's a pretty
pretty crazy arc you really it's it's
like so spider-man
theme to do that you know like to
realize what i've done i must sacrifice
myself now
i thought it was a great game and i
can't wait to up get up finally get a
ps5 and upgrade the damn thing because
story-wise it might not be a bit as big
it might not be as ambitious of a story
they're telling
yet i thought in terms of introducing
miles or else
as spider-man to play the game i thought
i found it to be a very
focused personal heroic tale by the end
it did really move me and it's a perfect
segue
getting you ready for the next
spider-man game because i hope you can
hop around between playing as peter
that's what i'm getting that's what i'm
hoping for too because that would have
been
not confusing but it wouldn't have as
much depth as now we
where we get like we've already had a
whole storyline with miles going into
the next game so it's going to be nice
like not having to fill that
in yeah we can just focus on the next
storyline so
i'm just this game just i mean i was
already pumped for the next spider-man
game but this just makes me even more
pumped yeah and i can't wait for
whenever we get that i would assume in
two or three years
it'd be cool if it is kind of like a
hybrid where it's a sequel to the first
spider-man game and a sequel to miles
morales which is which
it is it has to be especially with the
way the uh mid-credits scene is
here for sure but it would be cool if
they treat that game like it really is a
sequel to both so it feels like a
culmination game
absolutely all right guys well
spider-man mozzarella what'd you guys
think of the game did you enjoy it
overall was it let down in any way
was it more than you wanted was it
exactly tell us below
thanks andrew for coming by follow him
on social media links in the description
box subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell
we'll catch you guys soon